hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in section six of his inquiry concerning
human understanding
david hume is considering the topic of
probability the section is titled of
probability
and if your understanding of probability
is primarily oriented around what we
nowadays call
probability and statistics and very much
along the lines of mathematics
you're going to want to think in a
somewhat broader sense that the term
actually has
not only in hume's own time but but also
in our own time as well
where the probability is it can be
something that's a measure
but it can also be something that we
could say is
felt it's really sort of a modality of
things when we say something is merely
probable
we're not just saying that it's purely
possible we're also
not saying that it's absolutely
necessary but it's somewhere
in between there sometimes we can give
numbers for it based on
some sampling sometimes it's more of a
sense that we have like well i think
this is likely
but you know if i had to give it a
number
i don't know somewhere between 65 and 80
percent right
so there's a lot of things that we
consider to be probable
and hume uh begins us in a very
interesting way
he he tells us that there really is
no chance there's no such thing as
chance in the world so
you know he's beginning by talking about
something that's going to play a role
in what what follows the probability of
chance
but he tells us there really isn't any
such thing what's actually going on are
ignorance of the real
cause of any event has the same
influence on the understanding
and begets a like species of belief
or opinion so what he's what he's really
saying there is that
all of our thoughts that that some
things happen
randomly by chance and there could be
probabilities assigned to something like
the role of a dice
but it's it's totally random how it
works
um he's saying that all of that is is
really imaginary on our part
it could be part of a collective
imagination he doesn't consider that
possibility
or it could be the individual human
being's imagination but but
there is no such thing as absolute
randomness now that's kind of a
startling thing
for somebody who's just spent all these
chapters before that saying well we
don't really know the the causes of
things to to assert
with such you know
such confidence but i suppose you could
find an argument for
for that although he's not really
providing one for
that degree of confidence that he has
then he distinguishes
two different kinds of probability
and the first is probability
which is he says arising from a
superiority of chances
on any side and what we should say here
is perceived
or imagined superiority of chances and
then he says according as this
superiority increases
and surpasses the opposite chances the
probability receives a proportionable
increase and begets still
higher degree of belief or ascent to
that side in which we discover the super
superiority and this makes good sense
because belief is not something that's
all or nothing for hume it is a feeling
right it's a sentiment
and so the the more certain we feel
about something the more
strongly we believe in it or the more
strongly we feel that sentiment that we
we call belief and
so if we if we think about the example
of the sides of a dice that he likes you
know this is a very
easy intuitive one think about a single
die
and it's got numbers from one to six on
it right you've probably used these in
board games or you've seen them on
computer
modelings you throw the dice what is the
chance that any one single number is
going to come up
if you say anything other than one and
six
you you know i'd like to know the reason
why because
most of us would say well there's six
six faces
any one of them could come up so
therefore it's a one in six
chance what if you label
two sides of the die with the same
number so there's two ones and then
there's a two three four and a five
well then one becomes twice as probable
right and if you throw the die
you'll say well i'm not believing that
it's necessarily going to come up one
there's only actually a one and three
chance of that
but that's a lot stronger than coming up
five or two
and similarly if we throw two dice
what's the most common number
seven because there's six combinations
right out of 36 so one and six
chance whereas rolling a 2 or rolling a
12
you got a 1 in 36 chance now we can do
all that sort of stuff
mathematically and that would be you
know what hume is calling relations of
ideas in other parts
it's quite simple to do and we can
imagine to ourselves that that's the way
things are going to work
now in reality no die
is absolutely perfect there's going to
be like a little bit more weight on one
side
than on another perhaps just because of
the drilling the holes into it
or the dye gets worn in certain ways but
you know we don't fully understand
all these things unless we're the ones
who are skewing
the uh the dye you know we're rolling
what we call loaded
dice so he says that
the process of the thought or reasoning
may seem trivial or obvious but to those
who consider it more narrowly that is
more closely it may afford matter for
curious speculation
it seems evident when the mind looks
forward to discover the event which may
result from the throw of such a diet
considers the turning up of each
particular site is alike probable right
so he says this is the very nature of
chance
to render all the particular events
comprehended in
it equally
what does he say entirely equal
now he says that
the concurrence of these several views
or glimpses imprints an idea more
strongly on the imagination gives it
superior force and vigor
renders its influence on the passions
and affections more sensible
and in a word begets that reliance or
security which constitutes the nature of
belief and opinion
when we imagine that the the likelihood
is approaching
you know every single time it's going to
come up this way
and that's really all that he has to say
about the probability arrive
arising from perceived chances i mean
the one thing that we can say is
there is no real chance so this is
purely
imaginary but it could derive to some
degree from experience you could roll a
bunch of dice
if somebody actually doubts it have them
do that sort of experiment
people are not particularly good at that
i think there's a lot of people
who tend to think that they can have
some sort of influence on the spin of a
roulette wheel or the throw of a dice or
what's going on with cards
and that's why a lot of people lose
money at gambling
there's other reasons as well now
probability of causes
this hume thinks is actually real
so this describes something that happens
with
us human beings and he says listen
there's some things
where the connections remember causality
for hume is constant connection right
or constant conjunction um
they're uniform and constant so he gives
the example of gravity is
is a you know prime case
gravity could turn off it's possible you
know that
even though we've observed it happening
all the time throughout our life
that it could work differently you know
in the next minute that's
conceivable but nobody expects that
that's going to happen
we we give it a probability of of you
know one
meaning that it's going to happen in
every case he also asserts
uh and this makes sense in his time um
that fire is always burned water
suffocated every human creature
we could find something you know some
interesting exceptions somebody walks
through a fire
doesn't get burned we're like oh look at
that case over there but that doesn't
mean that we're not gonna expect that
when we put our own hand in the fire
it's not gonna burn our
our hand or that if we immerse ourselves
under water
that we're not going to drown right so
as a matter of fact you could say that
that people
murdering is based on the supposition
that
that stuff is actually going to work so
some of these connections are very very
likely
he says that there's other causes which
have been found more
irregular and uncertain so
he gives two interesting medical
examples
opium is a soporific it makes people go
to sleep
in part because they're high right but
it doesn't always affect everybody in
exactly the same way
rhubarb he says is a per
rhubarb is not always proved to purge
but um
you know it will in most cases and then
he says okay well what happens
when things don't work that way
when for example i take a sip of my
coffee and i'm like you know i put
some some cream into my coffee this is
going to make it taste better for me
because i like the you know the fat and
the sweetness and all that
along with the bitterness of the coffee
and i take oh this is awful right i spit
it out
well i start looking for other reasons
or i you know i could doubt that cream
has a certain
taste in general but that's not usually
where i go and he talks about
philosophers
the philosophical attitude towards this
will be to assume well there's other
things going on
you know again we don't we don't fully
understand the causality
at work the causality could be complex
so maybe the cream
was off that day right and or maybe i
got a bad batch or maybe we could go on
and on and on
with all sorts of examples maybe there's
something in that particular coffee that
interacted with the
cream which is perfectly normal in a
weird way
so he says that uh philosophers don't
ascribe this to any irregularity in
nature but suppose that some secret
causes in the particular structure of
parts
have prevented the operation so like you
know fire
didn't burn right somebody we would we
would start looking and say
what's going on with that person's body
or what's going on with that fire
now he doesn't think that most people
approach probability in this
philosophical or scientific way he says
that what we do
instead he says our reasonings are the
same as if this principle had no place
being determined by custom to transfer
the past to the future and all
inferences where the past has been
entirely regular and uniform
we expect the event with greatest
assurance and leave no room for any
contrary
supposition the sun will rise i might
not see it because there's clouds but i
don't doubt that there's a sun there if
someday the sun goes
out well we're screwed if it does we
won't be doing philosophy very long
but if it were to go out and we were to
somehow stay alive
um well then we would start to consider
it to be just probable
and not absolutely certain then he says
where different effects have been found
to follow from causes which are
to appearance exactly similar all these
various effects must occur to the mind
in transferring the past of the future
and enter into our consideration when we
determine the probability
of the event and so here we're talking
about
not certainty but probability though we
give the preference to that which has
been found most
usual notice that term and believe that
this effect will exist we must not
overlook the other effects
but must assign to each of them a
particular weight and authority in
proportion as we found it to be more or
less frequent
he gives the example of snow or frost in
january
and it's a very interesting example
because he says okay so
on any given january day you can expect
that there's going to be
frost now remember too he's writing up
in scotland
which on the one hand you know is is
quite
far north but on the other hand is
getting
uh the effect of the warming effects at
some degree of the sea
right so you know
if we're thinking about january and
we're thinking about scotland
then we can say oh there's a pretty high
probability there's going to be
snow or frost on the ground right
we go further south say to italy
maybe not probably fairly unlikely
or we go to you know north africa
well you know i suppose it could happen
there it snows in texas sometimes
but it's really unlikely you know here
in wisconsin
if you know we're in january um now it's
interesting here because
global warming has changed the climate
in this state where i grew up
if you were to ask me when i was a kid
hey is it going to be
cold and snowy and and you know frozen
over in january
yeah of course look around what's it
been like every year
we've had some days where it's actually
been
quite spring-like in january here in
milwaukee
and everybody's like wow this is really
strange this is unseasonable
it's possible the weather people are not
totally surprised by it
the rest of us are and why because we're
working with kind of
old data from our old customs and habits
and he says this probability varies
according to the different climates and
approaches to a certainty in more
northern kingdoms and he says here then
it seems evident when we transfer the
past to the future in order to determine
the effect which will result from any
cause
we transfer all the different effects in
the same proportion
as they've appeared in the past and
conceive
one to have existed 100 times for
instance another 10 times another
once and he says all these views
concur in one event they fortify and
confirm it to the imagination
they get that sentiment which we call
belief and give
its object the preference above the
contrary event which is not supported by
an equal number of experiments
and recurs not so frequently to the
thought in transferring this
uh from the past to the future so this
what's going on here
is we're sort of carrying around all
these memories of past
experiences what he calls experiments
and we project
onto the present and the future what
we've seen
in the past we project
it to a certain degree with a certain
amount of probability that then we
feel as belief so
there you know there's some things where
we might say ah i don't i don't have
a high degree of confidence in this i
mean it could happen
but i don't really know and then there's
other things we're like yeah
of course it's going to go that way i
mean i'm not 100
sure but i'm 99.9 percent sure we
we say we're usually overestimating the
the degree of probability in those sorts
of cases when somebody says they're 99.9
sure odds are they aren't so
that's a fitting place to bring this to
a close
hume needs to bring this up because
when it comes to causality there are
some cases where we do have constant
conjunction
but there are so many other cases where
we
don't actually observe that and what we
see instead
is you know this case is is happens more
often this case happens less often
and we assign a higher probability and a
lower probability
on that basis
you